Do you want to hear a story about the wild?
Anna
I'm Sheriff Alan Cooper
I'm the one who found you. You're gonna be with me until you identify any relatives that you might have
She's a girl that was kept in her father's attic
Can we close it? The wildling.
What's the wildling? Does your dad tell you that?
His teeth are sharp.
And so are his nails.
He ate all the other children
You're the last one left
Have you ever seen a wildling? In my dreams.
It's okay, you're safe here.
We detected a high concentration for the Pirela in her system
whoever did this wants to slow down her maturity
I really need to know, did someone hurt you?
She's asking too many questions
Hey ! What's the matter ?
What happened last night?
I wanna help you! What is a wildling Anna?
Learn from the town said they got every last one of them
But that isn't quite true, is it?
You're the last one left.